c'est à première vue une petite ville de
galice sans histoire une ville médiévale
sur le chemin de compostelle où l'on
passait sans s'arrêter
mais aujourd'hui pontevedra est devenu
un modèle que beaucoup tentent de copier
ici pas de congestion pas de klaxon pas
de pollution à pontevedra
le piéton est roi
l'architecte du changement c'est luis
miguel chau fernandes élu maire de la
ville en 1999 il a entrepris de
transformer complètement ses principes à
savoir le capteur fait nul contre avant
14 mille voitures passaient dans cette
rue chaque jour et la prof est à peine
la place d'espagne la base sur la place
d'espagne
in an passé vingt-huit mille c'était
davantage que sur la voie de
contournement de l'autoroute c'était
bestial en quelques mois les voitures
sont chassés du centre ville les rues
deviennent piétonnes la circulation
automobile est réduite de 90%
ponte vedra est transfiguré
[Musique]
ap y est là
ici il y avait auparavant un bruit
constant de klaxon les gens coincés dans
les embouteillage de s'énerver et
klaxonnaient il tournait en rond sans
fin la recherche d'un stationnement
je pense que les gens sont plus heureux
maintenant les voitures n'ont pas
totalement disparu de ponte vedra
mais tout est fait pour en limiter
l'usagé à ce qui est vraiment essentiel
les livraisons par exemple et le
stationnement est strictement
réglementée 15 minutes maximum
tout dépassement de la période autorisée
et sévèrement punis 150 dollars damant à
l'entrée de la ville d'immenses
stationnements gratuits ont été
installés les gens venant de l'extérieur
sont invités à y laisser leur voiture et
ont continué leur chemin à pied
c'est ce que fait désormais chaque matin
susanna otero alvarez une promenade
santé de 15 minutes
intégré dans sa routine quotidienne et
qu'elle apprécie génial de pouvoir
marcher dans le centre de pontevedra
avec des enfants sans se préoccuper des
voitures ça nous donne un vrai sentiment
de sécurité
c'est génial je te parlera dans les rues
des panneaux semblables à des plans de
métro indique le temps nécessaire pour
se rendre à destination
la mesure a fonctionné au delà de toute
espérance
aujourd'hui les deux tiers des
déplacements en ville ce fonds soit à
pied soit à vélo ce qui a permis de
réduire les émissions de co2 de 75%
a ponte vedra même là où circulent les
voitures
le piéton est désormais au centre des
priorités tout a été repensé en
conséquence la vitesse limitée à 20 ou
30 km heure et les passages piétons ont
été surélevés pour forcer les voitures à
ralentir
résultat depuis la transformation de la
ville le nombre d'accidents mortels a
été divisée par dix et aucun décès n'est
à déplorer au cours des sept dernières
années
la mesure a aussi permis de redynamiser
le centre ville qui a accueilli en
quelques années
douze mille nouveaux habitants les rues
ils sont plus animée et les commerçants
s'estime gagnant après la fellation
coach est projeté au parc ovale une
ville sans voitures c'est positif pour
le commerce
ça donne une meilleure audience pour
faire des achats sans la pression des
voitures sans la fumée sans le bruit
c'est beaucoup plus agréable était au
début
inquiet voire réticents les habitants de
ponte vedra sont aujourd'hui plus que
convaincu le maire miguel hernandez
vient d'être réélu pour un quatrième
mandat qui me satisfait le plus c'est
l'orgueil que ressentent les habitants
qui ont l'impression de vivre dans la
meilleure ville au monde
il est fan de chaussures à la mode mais
le travail est loin d'être terminé
la ville est un chantier perpétuel de
plus en plus de russes ont transformé à
la demande des citoyens et pontevedra
est devenu une référence mondiale
un modèle bientôt copié par madrid la
capitale et plus de 130 villes à travers
l'espagne